or mes amis mes chers amis c'est vous
simple lille est à feu et à sang comment
tenez regardez moi c'est épouvantable
n'est ce pas monsieur villeneuve
qu'avez-vous je ne faisais jamais vue en
raison de tenues aussi d'ebrahim
vous en prie ma chère amie tout ceci ne
prête guère à sourire car vous avez
trouvé le mot juste j'ai rencontré
effectivement en ouragan et stora quand
on s'appelle kazim kazim ou ragots et
c'est casimir qui vous a mis dans un
temps un téléthon oui et je ne suis pas
la seule victime il a mis du fluide
glacial sur la chaise du chef du bureau
de poste oui et quant aux facteurs il a
trouvé des grenouilles dans sa sacoche
et mademoiselle chute et s'est vu offrir
en guise de cadeau à bouquet de fleurs
avec les flammes sont propres chapeau je
sais pas ce qui lui prend est devenu
complètement fou espèce assez stupéfiant
alors là il y va un peu fort mais quand
même je n'arrive pas ou de tôle et ma
parole mais on ne sait pas ce que j'ai
vu dire monsieur 10,9 de sa raison de
parler a beau vous me rassurez
vous écouter il arrive je fais les amis
à bientôt nécessaire le moi je vais
continuer à lire mon livre ici en ayant
l'air de rien
[Musique]
je salue
je te laisse
pas prendre à françois ouimet un peu de
ballons je sais pas j'en ai jamais cette
bon et bien dans leur plus petit
mais fou qu'est ce qui te souvenir
consacré à deux mains du sage mais enfin
mais quand vont-ils faire pour être sage
mais coûteux va voir julie elle te
donnera la recette de la série bon bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais bien savoir comment il faut
faire pour devenir sage être toujours
aubigny sens comme les enfants sur les
images
surtout quand on met
moi avec des rêves plein la tête
on a des gestes maladroits si taux plein
dit moi l'art sert
empirique et fait plaisir
que tu veux
et gagner tu peux bien sage sans savoir
et b
[Musique]
les photos
c'est merveilleux
thibault sous zéro
[Musique]
m'arrive de temps en temps de partir en
claquant la porte ce n'est pas que je
sois méchant c'est la colère qui
m'emporte
[Musique]
il arrive que je
car avec les meilleurs de mes copains et
s'interpose sans crier gare
pour vérité fait plaisir
c'est camille tout devient seul son
savoir et va lui
rendre à mener autour
c'est quand
je veux bien essayer
pour diminuer bêtise se faire plaisir
pour monde entier ce sera dur pas que tu
dis
en somme un secret monsieur du snop et
le acteurs julie mademoiselle futaie
compte aussi parfois des erreurs
je serai bien savoir comment il faut
faire pour devenir sage d'être toujours
obéi sans comme les enfants sur les
images
hajjar surtout quand on est homme
avec tes rêves
on a des gestes maladroits mais j'ai
bien compris la rue
alors tu as compris oui d'accord bon
alors que puis-je faire pour te rends
concertiste et bien coup de casimir sera
gentil laisse moi tranquille mon travail
est et va t'amuser au fond du jardin tu
veux bien bon bon bon d'accord je te
laisse cependant la françois un pan
soins oui oui qui est il que ce qu'est
ce que je pourrais faire pour rendre
service à un eh bien tu me laisses lire
tranquillement et du va t'amuser
gentiment à l'autre bout du jardin alors
oui
on vous n'êtes pas drôle tous les deux
aujourd'hui alors
bon
tu as vu kazimi je n'ai jamais vu comme
ça je sais pas ce qui lui arrive
allons lui demander ce qu'il a
casimir mon vieux casimir ton patron
qu'est ce qui t'arrive pas bien rien
pourquoi et ses 1000 rue passes ton
temps à l'aide d'un bout à l'autre du
jardin bah oui vous ne voulez pas que je
vous rendre service
alors j'essaye de suivre votre conseil
et de me faire plaisir à ma mère m'a
encouragé à bout d'un autre du châtelet
oui oui oui je cours et je me dis
casimir va voir là bas si j'y suis 1
casimir veux-tu me faire plaisir va voir
là bas si j'y suis bon secours pardon et
je maudis casimir veux tu arrives voir
là bas si j'y suis alors je cours je
cours et je me dis qu'un génie veut
aller voir l'avant si j'y suis
ah bon
[Musique]